متابعه ما يجري على حدود غزه حيث فجر
مقومون فلسطينيون عبوه الناسفه قرب اليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه كانت تعمل عند الحدود مع
قطاع غزه
ظهر اليوم القناه الثالثه عشره في
التلفازات الاسرائيليه افادت وهي التي
اوردت هذا النبا افادت ان الاليه وهي
جرافه عسكريه كانت تقوم بنشاط هندسي عند
الحدود حسب تعبيرها لم يسفر ذلك عن اي
اصابات في حين ان دبابه اسرائيليه قصفت
مناطق داخل قطاع غزه ردا على هذا التفجير
ماذا ايضا في التفاصيل والمزيد منها معنى
مراسله الجزيره من غزه هبه عكيله هبه
[موسيقى]
نعم قد اعلنت جيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل ان
هناك حدثا امنيا على الحدود الشرقيه
لمدينه خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه
وحسب شهود عيان فان اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه
وكما يطلق عليها
اليات الهندسيه الاسرائيليه وتقوم عاده
بعمليات تمشيط للمناطق الحدوديه كانت تقوم
بعمليه تنشيط في المنطقه الحدوديه وتحديدا
عند السلك الحدودي لمنطقه شرق خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه حيث تم تفجير عبوه ناسفه
كانت مزروعه في المكان في هذه الاثناء رد
الجيش الاسرائيلي باطلاق القذائف على
المناطق الحدوديه في هذه المنطقه وعلى
مراصد
المراقبه لتابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وايضا على اراضي زراعيه حسب شهود عيان فان
احد المواطنين قد اصيب اصابه طفيفه ولكن
رسميا وحسب المصادر الطبيه هنا في قطاع
غزه لم يبلغ عن وقوع اصابات وان كان شهود
العيان في هذه المنطقه قد سمعوا تحذيرات
الجيش الاسرائيلي للمزارعين الاسرائيليين
في الجانب الاخر في الشريط الحدودي
تحذيرات باخلاء المكان وابعاد المزارعين
عن تلك المنطقه تحسبا لتطور الاوضاع ولكن
الاوضاع حتى هذه اللحظه هو اطلاق عدد من
القذائف من قبل الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تتواجد في المنطقه
الحدوديه باتجاه المناطق الحدوديه وباتجاه
مراصد
للمراقبه لتابعه للمقاومه في منطقه شرق
مدينه خان يونس جنوب
غزه ومن المعروف ان الاوضاع الميدانيه منذ
الليله الماضيه تشهد التوتر وتشهد اوضاع
غير طبيعيه تخوفا من تطور الاوضاع وكانت
قد اطلقت صفارات الانذار فجر اليوم في
المناطق الغلاف
غلاف قطاع غزه وقد اعلن عن اطلاق قذيفه من
قطاع غزه ولكن حسب
المصادر الاعلاميه وحسب مصادر محليه فان
هذه القذيفه سقطت داخل حدود قطاع غزه ولكن
التوتر كان قائما من تحذيرات الاسرائيليه
من اي
قطاع غزه
نعم لنعود الى حدث تفجير العبوه هذه
العبوه استهدفت جرافه عسكريه
في هذه
في هذه المناطق الحدوديه من المعروف ان
المقاومين الفلسطينيين يقومون بزرع هذه
العبوات تحسبا من اي اقتحامات واي اعمال
عسكريه اسرائيليه في هذه المناطق
واليوم كان هناك تجريف وكان هناك عمل
عسكري اسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه يمكن ان
نقول ان هذه الاعمال الاسرائيليه هي تقوم
بها القوات الاسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي
بصوره دوريه في هذه المناطق على طوال
الحدود الشرقيه لقطاع غزه ولكن عندما
يتواجد مقومون في المكان يقوم المقومين
بتفجير هذه العبوات التي تم زرعها للتصدي
لاقتحامات الجيش الاسرائيلي في غالب
الاحيان نقول عنها ان هذه الاعمال هي
اعمال اعتياديه ولكن الحياه اليوميه هي
تشكل خطر كبير على المواطنين الذين يسكنون
هذه المناطق الحد
وديه يتواجد
ون
في هذه نعود الى تفجير العبوه
الناسفه
يعني كما تقول التلفزه
الاسرائيليه كانت دبابه دبابه عسكريه تقوم
باعمال هندسيه حسب
تعبيرها المعلومات حتى الان انه لا اصابات
في تفجير هذه العبوه هذا صحيح
نعم
نعم نعم لم يبلغ عن ان هذه العبوه اصابت
بشكل مباشر هذه الاليه
الاسرائيليه الدبابه وكما يقال عنها هي
وحدات هندسيه تقوم بعمليات تجريف في هذه
المناطق الحدوديه في بعض الاحيان تقوم
باصلاح
السياج الحدودي وفي بعض الاحيان تقوم
بالدخول داخل مناطق قطاع غزه وتقوم
بعمليات تجريف وتقوم باطلاق النار واطلاق
القذائف على المزارعين المتواجدين في هذه
الاراضي الحدوديه وهي غالبا اراضي زراعيه
وان كان يتواجد فيها بعض المنازل حالات من
الرعب حالات من التهديد المتواصل من قبل
هذه الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تتعدد
الاسماء في بعض الاحيان يقال ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقوم بعمليات تمشيط في هذه
المنطقه في بعض الاحيان يقال بان عم ليات
ووحدات هندسيه تقوم باعمال اصلاح لهذا
الجدار ولكن ما حدث اليوم هو تم تفجير ولم
يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بان هذه الاليه
العسكريه قد تم اصابتها اصابه مباشره وحتى
هنا الشهود العيان من مزارعين ومن مقومين
الذين كانوا يتواجد في المكان لم يتحدثوا
عن اصابات مباشره لهذه الاليه العسكريه
الاس